it's important to underline
that close to 90
of truckers in this country
are vaccinated
like close to 90 of canadians
over the past many months and years now
canadians have stepped up
to protect each other to protect our
frontline workers to protect our elders
to protect our young people
to protect people like truckers who are
putting food on our grocery store
shelves
canadians have stepped up to do the
right thing to protect
the freedoms and the rights of canadians
to get back to the things we love to do
we know
the way through this pandemic
is by getting everyone vaccinated and
the overwhelming majority close to 90
percent of canadians have done exactly
that
the
small fringe minority
of people who are on their way to ottawa
or who are
holding unacceptable
views that they're expressing
do not represent
the views of canadians who have been
there for each other who know
that following the science
and stepping up to protect each other
is the best way to continue to ensure
our freedoms our rights our values as a
country